support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready
I'm Alice Rivlin and I'm a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution
well budgets are all alike there's never
quite enough revenue to do what you'd
really like to do so working with a
budget whether it's a company or a
school or the federal government is
always a question of looking at how can
you do the things you need to do more
efficiently so that costs are less and
how can you get more revenue in a down
market that's pretty hard because the
revenue is falling and super efficiency
may not get you to balance
companies tend to become suddenly
risk-averse companies and banks and
others and afraid to take risk in a
recession that's not necessarily the
right response but it is a natural one
if you've been burned to hold back the
government is trying very hard at the
moment to overcome this risk aversion on
part of businesses and banks and
consumers people are just very worried
right now about doing anything whether
it's buying or producing and that is
inhibiting the recovery
the benefits of starting a company in a
recession may well be that nobody else
is doing it or that you get the benefit
of the talents of people you couldn't
have afforded to attract when the
economy was really going well but here
are some really creative people that
want to get together and help you get
your business off the ground and they
are willing to work for relatively
little because they haven't got anything
else to do
if the United States is to keep up in
the global race we have to be very
entrepreneurial and very oriented toward
technological change that's our Forte
anyway I think President Obama is right
in emphasizing increased contributions
to to science we need our startup
companies which make a lot of the
positive changes in the economy the
general industries that will benefit
least I think are probably at least for
a while luxury retail and the things
that sort of went over the top when we
were having a big boom
we've seen very high growth rates in
developing countries especially recently
China in India that's going to continue
they have the Chinese have been very
dependent on exports for growth they
will have to shift more over time toward
investing in their own economy and their
own consumer sector and that will not
not be easy but we will certainly see
continued high growth rates from
economies that have a lot of potential a
lot of people and a lot of resources and
need to maximize the use of those
resources the developed economies like
the United States and Europe will
probably grow slower but if we get our
economy back in shape and our banking
system functioning again we can
certainly have a positive growth
probably always hard to stay creative
and staying motivated but it may be most
difficult when things are going really
well when they're not going well when
they're obstacles to be overcome a lot
of people are at their most creative
support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready